- One, two, three, four, five.
Hello, hello, hello.
Okay, here we go.
I wanna explain to you
what a recession is.
I'm doing this because
you're gonna hear this word
a lot lately.
And depending on how bad it gets,
you'll likely feel its effects.
So give me 12 minutes
to explain recession.
Plus, of course,
the inevitable time it
takes me to read an ad,
which is something I must do
in order to pay my employees
and feed my children.
I'm sure you can understand.
I spent four years in
university studying economics
preparing for this very
moment, so let's go.
- Are we at a turning point
headed for a recession?
- Storm clouds of recession looming
and the storm is really coming.
- With inflation at a 40-year high,
many experts warn of a
possible economic slow down.
- A recession is almost inevitable.
We use the word "economy"
to summarize what is
literally billions of things.
Billions of people making
billions of decisions
all connected to each other,
and yet the result of
all of these decisions
is one of two things,
this line either going up or going down.
(ominous music)
This all-encompassing number on a graph
is called the gross domestic product, GDP,
which, by the way, is kind
of the most undescriptive,
useless title ever given to anything.
GDP is like the receipt of an economy.
Every single thing that was
made and sold in an economy
all added up into one giant number.
Now there's a very technical definition
that you can go explore in the sources
if you're that kind of person,
but for now, just imagine every TV
and piano lesson and slice
of pizza and car wash
and pair of shoes and
smartphone and video game,
everything that the people purchased
from the businesses in
your economy in one year
all added up and packed into this one dot
and plopped on a graph.
So what we're looking at here
is Britain's GDP in 1990.
Everything that the economy made and sold
to the people added up to
about a trillion pounds.
That was their GDP for that year.
This is the best way that we can summarize
how big an economy is,
how much it produces,
how well it's performing year after year.
Let's look at a graph.
This is what GDP looked
like in the old days,
like in the agrarian days.
You had ups and downs year by year,
but really, overall, this
graph is pretty flat.
The economy didn't really
have an upward trend.
It wasn't growing.
That's because back in the 1300s
the economy was a
completely different world
than what we live in today.
It was pegged to things like farming,
which was pegged to things
like weather or plague or war.
So like here's the Black Death
that killed 40% of Europe's population,
and here is the Great Frost,
a weather event that
ruined a bunch of crops
and therefore made the
economy shrink for a year.
Okay, so this is how it
was in the agrarian days,
but brace yourself for what happens next.
(upbeat music)
This flat line just
turned into a steep cliff,
and that's because humans
started doing science,
not just to make themselves smarter,
but because they were incentivized to,
to make more stuff to,
make it more efficiently.
All of this happening as
humans were developing
and spreading a new set of economic rules,
rules that rewarded those who invented,
produced, and sold stuff
that made life better
for both the buyer and the seller.
The system was called capitalism.
Capitalism plus industry
was the cocktail that
allowed this to happen.
By the way, pause the timer for a second
because I need to just say it is painful
how little I'm able to
include on this topic.
Go into the sources and just poke around
and you'll see so much good juicy history
on capitalism and the
Industrial Revolution.
Let's move on. Back to the timer.
So every year people could
make more and more stuff.
They could sell more stuff.
And there was more and more GDP,
more stuff being made
and sold in the economy,
not just in England,
which is this graph we've
been using as the example,
but eventually in the whole world.
Okay, but there was a
catch to this new system.
Unlike the old agrarian days
where you could have a graph
that kind of stays
generally flat over time,
this new system was built off of the idea
that the line kind of has to go up.
Capitalism works because
it incentivizes people to
make products and
businesses that are better
and better every year,
more and more productive,
pushing this line higher
and higher every year.
And the kind of voodoo
magic of capitalism is
if the line doesn't go
up, bad things happen.
(dramatic music)
Okay, so here's where
it all comes together.
We're trying to get to recession right?
By the mid 1800,
the capitalist experiment
was fully underway,
at least in the western world and Japan.
The rest of the world was
being brutally exploited
to make all of this happen.
Anyway, topic of another story.
See How Europe Stole the
World, part one and two,
part three coming soon.
(exhales) The amount of
stuff being made and sold
in the economy was going up
more and more every year.
This graph is definitely going
up, but what about all these?
Soon a mysterious pattern
emerged in this line.
Every few years the
GDP graph would go down
for a little bit.
The amount of stuff being
made and sold would shrink,
not necessarily tied to
weather and war and plague,
but just cause.
Before eventually recovering
and continuing on its way up.
And these little dips in
the line we call recession,
a receding of the amount of
shit we can make and sell.
Here is the GDP of the
United States since 1948
and here are all the recessions.
There've been like 12.
I mean, we just got out of one of these.
We had a very short but dramatic recession
thanks to COVID-19.
But the last long recession was back here,
the financial crisis around 2008
the one that you probably think of
when you hear the word recession.
- Subprime derivative.
- A subprime mortgage meltdown.
- A housing bubble.
- Okay, wait, wait, wait.
But why does the graph go
down in the first place?
Like what makes it go down?
You can't answer that by
looking at just this big line.
You have to zoom into one of these dots
and see what has to happen
to create this number.
(upbeat music)
At the very heart of
the capitalist economy
you have two major players.
You've got people and businesses,
or as economists like to call
it, households and firms.
In this case, let's just say
the entire economy of your country is
actually the size of your neighborhood,
and you're going to your local bakery,
an important business in
your neighborhood economy.
You and your neighbors
show up to this bakery
and you pay $3 for a loaf of bread.
The bakery is a business
that uses that money to
pay its workers,
but these workers aren't like
some special class of people.
They're just other people in the economy
who also are gonna go spend money too.
The bakery also has to
pay rent to a landlord
who's also just another
person in the neighborhood.
So those people then go off
with their new money
that they just got paid
and they spend on other businesses
who also have workers
to pay and rent to pay.
And suddenly your money is flowing
to all the people who work in the economy,
and everyone's feeling good about it.
They have jobs, they have a solid income,
they can buy cool stuff.
The bakery and other
neighborhood businesses
feel this demand and they go,
"we need to hire more people
so we can make more bread."
And lucky for them, there are investors,
and the investors are
stoked on all of this demand
so they start investing in the bakery
and all the other businesses,
giving them money to hire more people,
to make more bread,
more buying, more jobs,
more stuff being added to the total.
The GDP is going up,
the economy is growing.
Okay, but what happens when
some outside force comes in
to disrupt all these good vibes?
It all starts when you show
up to your bakery one day
and you notice that something changed.
Suddenly the price of a loaf
of bread is actually $4.
And the baker's like,
"Sorry, dude! The price
of flour has gone up."
You know, inflation,
supply chains, whatever.
They say something.
But the point is what it does to you.
Suddenly you're feeling like, oh,
maybe I can't afford this bread.
Or even if you can, you
see that something's up
or maybe you hear that the
interest rate is going up,
something that we're
hearing about a lot lately.
And so now you're thinking, oh,
maybe I shouldn't spend money
on expensive artisan bread
but save that money and I can
actually get a good return.
If you're an investor,
the higher interest rate's
kind of freaking you out
because now it's more
expensive to borrow money.
You think twice before
investing in the bakery.
Another option is that
you're hearing rumors
about a coming economic downturn
because of some war somewhere,
and you judge that it would
be wise to save your dollars
instead of spend on expensive
artisan bread or whatever.
Meanwhile, your neighbors are seeing
and feeling the same things,
and they decide that this bread
is a little bit too expensive for them
and they'll just make bread at home.
Less bread is demanded
from the bakery, AKA,
there's a disruption in
your local bread market,
AKA, there's a mismatch
between bread demanded
and bread supplied.
The bakery hired too many
workers during the good times.
They now don't have the
revenue to pay them all,
so they have to lay some of
them off or cut their pay.
Unemployment is now going up.
"I lost my job today,"
says your sad looking
neighbor one evening,
which kind of freaks you out even more.
Maybe you should be more
careful about your spending.
And now it's starting to spread.
What was just a decision
to not buy bread anymore
means that many employees in
the neighborhood won't get paid
and now they can't go out and spend money,
which means that other
businesses have less revenue
to pay their employees,
and now more people are hearing about this
and deciding maybe they
don't wanna be spending,
and suddenly there are fewer
and fewer transactions,
less lending and investment.
And now this economy that was
once buzzing with activity
is experiencing a domino effect.
Less stuff is being made,
less stuff is being bought.
Your neighborhood economy
is literally shrinking.
It's making less stuff.
Your GDP is lower than
it was the year before.
Your neighborhood is in recession.
The point I wanna make here
is that this is the result
of loads and loads of people
making a bunch of micro-decisions
on whether or not to spend their money.
And because of the system we're in,
these decisions have a
massive chain reaction
that affects everyone who participates
in the economy, meaning everyone.
That's the blessing and
the curse of capitalism.
Okay, let's just pull
ourselves out of the analogy
with all the pretty animation
and talk about the real
world for a second.
You're probably wondering, are
we in a recession right now?
Are people spending less money
so that the economy makes less stuff?
Is GDP doing this?
I mean, maybe!
We don't know yet!
And especially with this one,
it's kind of a weird one.
It's hard to tell.
We're getting contradictory
signals from the economy.
Here in the United States
we had two quarters in a row,
which is like six months,
of a shrinking GDP,
and this, for a lot of analysts,
is the definition of a recession.
Two quarters in a row of
shrinkage? We're in a recession.
But then just a few weeks
ago, the news came out
that the third quarter of
2022, the economy grew again.
I mean it was by less
than 1%, but it grew.
So that's not a recession yet.
Plus, during a recession,
the number of unemployed people spikes.
But check out where the
unemployment rate is right now.
It's nice and low.
That's not recession.
So the signals are contradictory.
By the way, if you want a deeper dive
into how recessions are
officially classified and declared
and by whom, check the
sources in the description.
There's a whole super deep dive into that.
Most of you would be like
snoozing after two seconds
if I went into it.
What we do know is that people
are a little bit freaked out.
They're being more cautious
about their spending,
and that's because of a cocktail of causes
that you've heard about in the news.
COVID-19 giving way to energy prices
and supply chain disruptions
and this war in Ukraine.
The result is less of
this and more of this,
and that's because hundreds
of millions of people
are making hundreds of millions
of little micro-decisions
every day to spend less money
in an economy that only works
if everyone spends more money
and pushes businesses to make more stuff.
And that's the point I want to make here.
The big takeaway.
We talk about the economy like
it's some kind of science.
I mean, I have a degree in
economics, a social science.
We look at graphs, we do calculus,
and we feel like we're scientists.
And in a big sense we are.
But what this graph hides
is that what we're dealing
with here are people,
people who make decisions
based on how they feel,
and that's really hard
to predict and control.
We do it.
See the inflation video
for how the Fed is like a puppet master.
We do it, but it's really
hard to control and predict.
So a recession is almost certainly coming.
You may be watching
this in like nine months
and the recession is here.
I don't know.
The fact is by looking at
this line, what we can say
is that a recession is natural and normal.
It is a part of our
modern economic system.
It will likely come and then go.
People will lose jobs,
businesses will close,
and at some point, for a
million tiny little reasons,
things like policy and
just general feelings
in a bunch of people's guts,
this graph will stop going down
and it will start going up again.
That we can be sure.
(exhales) Do you know what
else we can be sure of?
I'm gonna keep making videos.
And in fact, I have just made one
of the most ambitious
videos in my entire life.
It is about Swiss bunkers.
There are bunkers
everywhere in this country.
And the result is this video game
(airplane flying)
I'm really proud of
that publishes next week
here on the channel.
(energetic music)
but I actually published it early.
It's available right now.
You can go watch it
literally like right now.
if you go to Nebula.
They turned their mountains
into a literal giant fortress.
Yes, you heard me right.
They turned their
mountains into a fortress.
Nebula is a platform
where I'm gonna start publishing
my videos a week early.
You can go watch them
before anyone else does
with no ads and no interruptions at all.
This is not a rock, this is a door.
If you like my videos,
you're gonna like the
stuff that's on Nebula.
Like this hour and a half long documentary
on the Colorado River
by Wendover Productions.
It's insanely well produced.
RealLifeLore, a YouTuber I deeply respect,
has a "Modern Conflicts" series
that is only available on Nebula.
Can't get it anywhere else.
In addition to tons more smart creators.
It seriously seems too good to be true.
So how much is this gonna cost you?
That's what you're all asking.
Well, if you go in through the front door,
just like go to Nebula and sign up,
it's five bucks a month or $50 a year.
But there's a hack for this
that makes it way cheap,
like ridiculously cheaper,
like less than a dollar a month.
Click the link in my description
and it'll take you to Curiosity Stream.
Curiosity Stream is a partner of Nebula
and they have this bundle deal right now
where if you sign up for Curiosity Stream
and you use my code, johnnyharris,
make sure to use the code
to support my channel.
Choose literally the cheapest plan.
It is less than a dollar a month
if you do the annual thing.
It doesn't say it here,
like it literally doesn't say it anywhere,
but if you do this plan
and you enter my code
when you're checking out,
you will get an email from Nebula
that says your Nebula
account has been activated,
create a password.
And now you get to watch
my videos a week early,
ad free, and tons of other
amazing ad-free content,
a lot of it exclusive to Nebula.
Doesn't exist anywhere else.
Curiosity Stream is full of
its own amazing repository
of documentaries.
But I'm telling you how to get into Nebula
for a dollar a month
so you can watch my videos a week early.
More than any other ad
read I have ever done,
I can say without a doubt
that clicking that link
and using that code,
johnnyharris, helps support this channel.
And it also helps support
independent YouTubers
who are trying to make really good stuff.
If enough people sign up
for Nebula using my link,
they are going to help support
a big ambitious documentary
project I wanna work on.
It's a documentary project
I can't really publish here on YouTube
'cause I have to play by sort
of the ad-friendly guidelines,
I have to play the attention economy game.
I love that, that's fine.
But Nebula wants to support me
making more and more ambitious stuff.
You signing up gets you
access to all this stuff
but also helps support
us make great stuff.
So anyway, literally just
choose any Curiosity Stream plan
and use my code, and that's it.
It's late.
It's getting dark out there.
Hope everyone's having a good winter.
And I'm tired.
It's a Friday today.
You're probably watching
this on some other day,
but I'm gonna go home and take a nap.
(energetic music)